hada had it a quick disclaimer before we
get into the interview the plants and
compounds mentioned in this episode are
illegal in many countries and even
possession can carry severe criminal
penalties this episode does not
constitute medical advice nor legal
advice and should not be construed as a
recommendation to use psychedelics there
are serious legal psychological and
physical risks fatalities have been
recorded so psychedelics are not for
everyone they can exacerbate certain
emotional problems certain diagnoses and
there have been as mentioned in very
rare cases fatalities so thanks for
being safe everybody
[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss welcome to another
episode of the tim ferriss show my guest
today is a fan favorite dennis mckenna
you can find him on twitter at dennis
mckenna 4. dennis has spent more than 40
years researching the interdisciplinary
study of amazonian ethnopharmacology and
plant hallucinogens he has conducted
extensive ethno-botanical field work in
the peruvian colombian and brazilian
amazon his doctoral research at the
university of british columbia focused
on the ethnopharmacology of ayahuasca
and ukuhei two tryptamine-based
hallucinogens used by indigenous peoples
in the northwest amazon he is a founding
board member of the hefter research
institute which has helped fund and
directly funded a lot of very good
science and was a key organizer and
participant in the wasca project the
first biomedical investigation of
ayahuasca used by the udv a brazilian
religious group he is the younger
brother of terence mckenna from 2000 to
2017 he taught courses on
ethnopharmacology as well as plants and
human affairs at the center for
spirituality and healing at the
university of minnesota in 2019 in
collaboration with colleagues he
incorporated a non-profit the mckenna
academy of natural philosophy currently
the academy has several projects
underway with the most immediate being
preparations for an upcoming conference
in the uk may 23rd to 26th that's 2022
espd55 we're going to talk a lot about
this which will cover a wide range of
topics related to
psychoethnopharmacology dennis emigrated
to canada in the spring of 2019 with his
wife sheila and now resides in
abbotsford british columbia the website
for the event that i just mentioned at
espd55.com
dennis welcome back to the show it's so
nice to see you again
thanks tim it's really great to be here
thank you for
welcoming me back
absolutely and i want to mention to
folks right up front that the first
episode covered a lot of ground i'm
going to try not to duplicate
too much
the
the title of the last episode for people
who want to check it out is dennis
mckenna the depths of ayahuasca 500 plus
sessions fundamentals advanced topics
science churches learnings warnings and
beyond so you get the idea if you want
to do a deep dive on not just ayahuasca
but certainly a lot of your biographical
details and more
listen to the first episode i'm going to
try to deliver on the promise
that i made at the end of the first
episode which was a teaser to a second
conversation which now we are in the
very beginning of during which i said we
might get into quote the really strange
and weird stuff end quote so i'm gonna
make an attempt to incorporate some
strange and weird stuff i don't think
it'll be very hard
i thought we could start
with a number of excerpts highlights
that i grabbed from the brotherhood of
the screaming abyss which chronicles
many of your life experiences adventures
and misadventures alongside your brother
and the many other people in your life
and i'm just going to pull out a section
here and you can feel free to revise or
update
or now refute anything that i bring up
but here here's the line
they were an excellent compliment to the
cannabis we don't have to get into all
the context before this which we spoke
constantly along with the occasional hit
derived from the shavings taken from our
fresh supply of banisteriopsis copy the
vine added to ayahuasca as a source of
the mao inhibiting compounds that's
monoamine oxidase inhibiting compounds
here's the part i wanted to hear you
expand on a bit we found that smoking
the bark while on mushrooms synergized
the closed eye hallucinations in a most
pleasant and intriguing way we dubbed
this serendipitous discovery vegetable
television so could you speak
a bit more please about the effect of
adding
the smoking of the bark to mushrooms and
what that experience
was or is like
it was pretty much an accidental
discovery
so many of these things are but we were
you know this is a good example of what
happens i guess basically when you start
mucking around with plants
you know and doing stuff that
maybe not be maybe not entirely safe but
you had to experiment it was just we
stumbled on it we were taking a lot of
mushrooms
and you know that's a whole other story
that we may or may not get into but we
were in a situation in the amazon when
we were doing mushrooms pretty much
constantly and when you're doing them
constantly you get a certain tolerance
built up and then you have to do larger
doses to get any effect
and we were as as it says there we were
smoking cannabis
pretty much constantly through this too
so we decided to just well what would
happen if we smoked some banasteriopsis
shavings with on the mushrooms and
it had this amazing effect you know
which anybody could replicate and i
don't think it's particularly
dangerous but we found that we could
take a hit
and then we would get this efflorescence
of visions that would that would just
gently rise and last you know two or
three minutes and then just kind of fade
away
and then you could take another hit and
you could repeat that it was kind of
like going up and down in a balloon
you could you could lose some ballast
and go a little higher or you could come
down
it was very pleasant actually it was
very nice
if you look at the
whole history of ethnopharmacology
for example the ayahuasca
we think of ayahuasca as being
essentially a mixture of two plants
but that's very
much a simplification of what ayahuasca
is you know there's a whole
pharmacopoeia of of plants that sort of
this galaxy implants that that is
associated with ayahuasca
not always taken with it sometimes taken
as admixture sometimes taken
as components of this dieta which is
very important in the in the sort of
ayahuasca
tradition the training of the curanderos
and so on
and
a lot of these plants are
not very well investigated
from a scientific point of view
but
the
it's it's an empirical science and and i
i guess the i guess the point is
you know in some ways these
practitioners shamans curanderos they're
really scientists in a certain sense
they're experimental about it and they
don't hesitate to say well what if i
take this and mix it with that
what's going to happen how is that going
to change the effect
sometimes they really regret those that
survive this process
you know make discoveries but there is
the potential to take the wrong things
people may may think that ayahuasca has
been pretty much figured out in terms of
botany chemistry pharmacology and so on
but that's not the case
there's a lot more to be learned about
ayahuasca there's numerous phds left to
be done
and particularly these admixture plants
are interesting
because some of them are
you know our psychedelic by themselves
or regarded to be but they may be used
with ayahuasca so this accumulated
knowledge that exists in this sort of
folk traditions if you will
is
not explored
or not certainly not codified and it's
ever-changing right
like
that's why
there is no such thing as a standardized
mixture of ayahuasca
because there is different
each preparation
is as different as the practitioners
that prepare it
it has their sort of
idiosyncratic stamp on it
i want to
underscore a few things that you said
and then raise some additional questions
so first i just want to
reinforce
how trial and error over hundreds or
thousands of years can produce some very
refined approaches to
solving different problems and i think
that this is well represented
in areas that are perhaps a little more
objectively accessible
by most markers than say psychedelics if
you look at
poisons used in the amazon and i've
certainly learned a lot about this from
our mutual friend mark plotkin who is an
impressive fellow in his own right and
has spent a lot of time in suriname and
other places
but if you look at kirari
for a very long time for instance
western scientists who later would take
that and use it as the basis for a lot
of modern anesthesia
saw that
various species of pepper
wild pepper were being added as
admixtures to this poison and they
after failing to do any type of assay
that that produced meaningful results
concluded that it was just primitive
superstition
and that was the conclusion for a long
time until
it was identified that i believe it's
bioperine in these constituent sort of
molecules found in pepper can actually
increase the bioavailability of these
poisons such that they're faster acting
and if you're shooting a monkey in the
canopy the last thing you want is for
that tail to wrap around a branch when
it dies so that it doesn't fall to the
floor
uh and so lo and behold it turned out
that yes there is there is a
very practical purpose for the inclusion
of this admixture and i'm sure there are
some false leads and there are things
that kind of remain that
won't be proven out in that same way but
i do i think there's an argument to be
made that
as you said a lot of phds
are yet to be earned looking at
these admixtures and just to provide a
bit of context on the diet and please
feel free to jump in and
add or refute anything that i say the
dieta
in many different tribes in many
different contexts is the
ingestion and some in some cases the
application
of plants that an individual is
attempting to better understand or
adopt and integrate as an ally and the
ayahuasca is
viewed as a master plan or a teacher
plant
you know effectively in some capacity a
vehicle for
getting to understand and know these
plants so over a period of time and
sometimes it's done in a fasting context
other times it's a very
bland diet
these plants may be not ingested at the
same time as ayahuasca but alternated
say one day on one day off
um or or otherwise
and then in certain cases as you were
mentioning there are these psychedelics
like uh like toei
that are
brewed with
ayahuasca which can be pretty dicey in
some cases
i want to ask you about
another
paragraph and that'll lead into my
question so so here's here's the
paragraph in the next two or three
sessions at don fidel's i experienced
the same sub threshold effects it
couldn't have been poor quality brew
others in the group including don were
clearly affected it was something wrong
with me for some reason i wasn't getting
it in quotation marks reflecting on
those first experiences i think that
ayahuasca is in ways a learned
experience if you don't know what to
expect nothing may happen
also my uptight hyper vigilance may have
prevented me from relaxing enough to
allow the experience to manifest
okay so this paragraph highlights
one
one brand of
sort of a null experience that i find
most mystifying about psychedelics
because
i have also had experiences and and many
others have where
they will
1 out of 10 1 out of 15 one out of every
20 sessions
have absolutely no effect even from
megadoses of ayahuasca and presumably
your
you know serotonin type 2a receptors
aren't just out to lunch for that period
of time and so it it begets all sorts of
questions so could could you speak to
ayahuasca as a learned experience
and
also comment on if you have any thoughts
these
zero
effect experiences
because in each case i can come up with
a plausible explanation for why if it
were possible for my psyche to negate an
experience it would have negated those
experiences in those settings
but it's hard for me to make heads or
tails out of
it's very hard to do any kind of
controlled study on this
right you can't do that i think what
this speaks to is that
ayahuasca or any
psychoactive drug
not just psychedelics but it happens in
psychedelics
the experience is
a combination of
pharmacology
pharmacogenetics the way that your
unique
body we're all biochemically unique in
the way your body handles
the absorption and the
elimination of of the substance
and the circumstances sentence setting
this
this
dynamic of the environment that we harp
on constantly is as the importance of
sentence
i forget who it was but some i think
maybe it was andy weil who once made the
observation psychedelics are a kind of
placebo
in a certain way and if you take them
under the wrong circumstances or
inappropriate circumstances
you're not going to get any effect
because
it doesn't sync with the
expectations that you may have or other
things and it just won't happen
you have to surrender to it you
literally have to surrender to it
to let it happen
but i think that
this whole area
of
how the
pharmacology and the expectations
interact
it's a dynamic
process that involves the medicine
your expectations
the dose
and your biochemical individuality and
all that i mean it's interesting for
example there are some people
who
most of us for example smoke dmt and
we're blown away right i mean dmt is
hard to ignore if you smoke it it's
profound very quick but
very intense experience there are people
who experience nothing
which is
rather strange
and and
so what's that about and without looking
into well okay so what's unique about
their serotonin
pharmacology maybe these people are like
genetic knockouts natural genetic
knockouts
maybe they don't have
high levels of 5-ht2a receptors or maybe
there's something maybe their mao is
super
super active or super high
but you know the problem tim with with
with studying this stuff is it it all
comes down to
these are case studies right so you
can't do a controlled experiment really
you can't do a group and really study
this effectively it's all about
well there's this one individual that no
matter how much he takes he or she takes
dmt
he's insensitive to it
and we never did figure it out it never
it never actually worked and
i've heard other cases like that i've
heard cases uh
these are all anecdotal stories but i
heard a case of someone who for example
was insensitive to dmt
but very sensitive to five methoxy dmt
yeah
why would this be it's just a mystery
what also
just it produces more questions than
answers certainly for me is when you
look longitudinally at the experience of
a single person so
like their
pharmacogenetics should be reasonably
stable you would think and let's just
say in my case where i'm extremely
sensitive to ayahuasca generally
speaking
and then in a handful of cases
have you know two or three cups and
absolutely
zero discernible effect and
i have my own subjective explanation for
why that plausibly could have happened
but
biochemically i don't know how that is
possible right now
because my expectation was that i would
feel the effect
and similarly there are cases where
even if we remove the the the expectancy
effect
there are certainly cases of people
being dosed let's just say
with lsd and any number of
incarnations and they
end up tripping their faces off even
though they hadn't planned on spending
the rest of their evening uh in the 17th
dimension right so
so i should also add just a quick note
related to the these the smoking of
the banisteriopsis copy
bark with mushrooms i've never
experienced that i find that actually
incredibly
i'm not recommending it for all the drug
disclaimers and everything else please
revisit episode one but i will say
everything we're discussing
or a lot of what we're discussing can go
terribly sideways
even if you are highly experienced so
we're not recommending you do any of
these things talk to your medical
professional etc etc right however all
of that having been said
i find what you did more interesting
than say
what
someone did who i may or may not know
which is
ingesting
harmine or harmaline or
tetrahydroharmine orally in combination
with ground
philosophy mushrooms where you you hit
the tennis ball or you hit the golf ball
more accurately and you can't un-hit it
and in that case just for people
wondering
the multiplier effect on the subjective
experience of mushrooms is about a three
to four x so if you were to take 1.5
grams of mushrooms and combine it with
the mao inhibitors in this way the sort
of subjective feeling is the intensity
of 4.5 let's just say grams so you want
to be aware of that but
the smoking is super interesting because
you can
titrate that
additive effect up or down exactly which
is the same reason why
i found
my experiences some of my experiences
with intravenous ketamine very
interesting
versus intramuscular for instance
because
in real time you can dial up or down the
intensity assuming you haven't pushed
yourself through the looking glass with
a huge bolus in the very beginning in
that case forget about it all bets are
off but if you're starting at a dose and
a drip on a per
like a kind of milligrams per kilogram
basis over 60 minutes
that you can manage
a conversation with then you can you can
kind of dial it up and down
which is extremely extremely interesting
because you're able to better observe
the effects at least
yeah i mean like you say all the caveats
you know about being careful with
with anything like this anything you're
doing
i i think that one should be careful one
thing about the mushroom smoked
banasteriopsis
you know thing is that it does seem very
gentle very easy to control again
your results may vary your mileage may
vary everybody's different if you're
super sensitive i've always been a
little puzzled
why people would want to
combine beta-carbolines with mushrooms
because they don't require it
they're orally active that's what's at
psilocybin aside you know apart from dmt
it does not require
activation by a monoamine oxidase
inhibitor and i'm a person that tends to
think
avoid combinations if possible
because every drug you add into the mix
complicates
the pharmacokinetic picture and
everything else potentially makes it
a little more hazardous so i to the
people that say well i can take
a gram and a half of mushrooms and
potentiate it with peganum harmona
and get a much higher effect my question
is well
why not take four grams of mushrooms and
let it go with that you know that is a
much
more straightforward approach yeah
you'll get to the same place
but this idea about titrating dose is
interesting that's another
approach to dmt that you can take that's
that's
interesting which i haven't worked with
it that much but vaping dmt in a volcano
vaporizer
i've had some of the most profound
experiences with dmt
that way
because you can
you you don't have to mess around with
the pipe you just get the bag full of
smoke and then you can deal with it if
you put under your tongue sublingually
a little bit of banisteriopsis tincture
like 10 minutes before you do this
then you can smoke the vapor in dmt and
again you get this ability to
just gently rise
up into the place and you can kind of
maintain that for a while
and then you can sort of drift back down
and then you can take another hit and
you can go back up there but you feel
this sense of
it it's very much less threatening i you
feel you don't feel the sense of being
out of control you just take three huge
hits of dmt it's it's kind of like okay
we're jumping off cliff here
open the umbrella hope for the best
but this is a much more
controllable way to approach it
and if it gets scary well you just let
yourself down gently and come in for a
gentle landing and if not
you can go to 28 000 feet or 50 000 feet
or
all the way into orbit if you want if
you
so i guess
if there's a point to this rep
route and dosage and the way that you
approach that is gonna
that's part of the dynamic you know of
this setting
drug
individual setting and dose
and that includes a route of
administration
i have not surprisingly a whole a whole
slew of questions that i'd like to ask
and i'm trying to i'm trying to sequence
them so we can
in some
rational way because i think some could
engender just a whole new branch of the
conversation let me let me start with
one that i've i've
heard you
discuss on some capacity before but i
can't remember the answer
and i'd just love your help we're
probably going to get into like
phylogenetic trees and all sorts of
stuff but i heard someone talking not
too long ago and they said something
along the lines
of well if you look at the
fact that we have
cannabinoid receptors in our brain
why else would we have those if it
weren't
for the fact that we were designed to
consume cannabis you know something
along those lines i think the logic was
was something like that
how how would you explain
the
uh the prevalence or existence of
receptors for these various types of of
of molecules i mean we could use
is it cannabinoids is that how you say
that correctly yeah i'm sure if i'm
pronouncing it correctly
what would your response to that be or
if you were sitting at a dinner table
and someone brought that up
where would you take it
i think it's not that complicated
actually the fact is
so we have cannabinoid receptors in our
brains
and uh
we have we actually have cannabinoids in
our brains we have these these peptides
called or these these prostaglandin-like
compounds called anandamines
and other types of things these are
effectively their our brain's own
cannabinoids
similarly you see this with opiates
opiate receptors in our brain bind to
these opiate peptides like endorphin and
dinorphin and right and those sorts of
things
and they just happen to bind to
the alkaloids from opium
and have that effect similarly with
serotonin receptors or dopamine
receptors all of these have their own
endogenous the term is in endogenous
ligands and
obviously for serotonin receptors their
serotonin is the endogenous ligand
but interesting new findings tim show
there's formally there was a lot of
there was excitement there still is
excitement about endogenous dmt
you know and it's all related to
the pineal gland and that sort of thing
not so much the current understanding is
that the pineal is not so important
but dmt occurs in the brain in certain
parts of the brain in rather high
amounts in the frontal cortex and this
hasn't really been discussed or studied
as much as it should my friend john
chavez has gotten into this and
rather deeply
so dmt is an endogenous ligand and dmt
is a very simple molecule it's only two
steps from tryptophan which isn't
everything which is one reason why you
find dmt in
plants animals fungi
you know i sometimes in my lecture say
nature is drenched in dmt
it's not uncommon at all
oh how did this come about well it came
about because these neurotransmitter
like compounds
found in the brain are also found in
plants and fungi and they have similar
evolutionary origins basically at some
point
the fungi the animals and the plants uh
split off from each other there's this
concept of the luca you know the
last universal
common ancestor
which was
nobody knows what it was but we know
that it had to have existed
and probably probably it already had
the the genetic machinery to make these
neurotransmitter like compounds and and
just like neurotransmitters in the brain
what they do is they facilitate
signaling their signal transduction
molecules right
but plants and fungi and everything else
use very similar molecules
sometimes the same molecules
for signal transduction
processes
in the ecosystem
plants modulate their relationship with
other organisms in the environment
through signal transduction and these
messenger molecules
the the plants make the
these sort of
they're called secondary compounds
and that
implies they're not important they're
absolutely important but what they do
plants substitute biosynthesis for
behavior
right plants
modulate optimize their relationship
with everything in the environment
because they can't respond they can't
run away
right they're stuck in one place
so they do it through chemistry
and sometimes you know this is like my
usual rap but sometimes the message is
very simple stay away get away from me
i'm poisonous you don't want to muck
with me you know other times the message
is
come closer let's symbiose let's form
relationships all of this is mediated by
the signal transduction processes which
is a
which is a special kind of of signal
signaling process in organisms that
involves
a receptor and a molecule that comes
from
somewhere outside or some other part of
the brain and actually binds into that
receptor so it's a
physical molecular interaction that's
what i mean by signal transduction
as opposed to say nervous
electrical nervous transmission which
also takes place
that's the myst it's not really a
mystery it's
we evolved from the same origins
not surprising that our brains have
neurotransmitter-like compounds that
resemble those we find in nature and the
interesting thing is something like
psilocybin is a good example psilocybin
has
you know phylogenetically we're pretty
sure that psilocybin has been around for
at least 75 million years
the higher mushrooms the basilio my
seeds
are very old long before there were
animal nervous systems for them to
interact with
but then animals did evolve and they
turns out they have interesting
effects with psilocybin what was
psilocybin doing
in nature before then well probably
insects it had to do with insects it was
either an attractant or a repellent
more likely and attractive
and there are some interest
we could go down that rabbit hole but
just like going to the go into the bar
for the local insects
right yes effectively yes
i mean you've heard of the psilocybin uh
cicadas
story no right i have not
oh how did i miss the psilocybin cicadas
story sounds like a punk band
it does really well i don't know do you
want to go into it
i do yeah of course i do you kidding me
yeah so very interesting
study came out a few years ago
so cicadas are those
things that spend like 17 years
underground and then they come out every
17 years or different species come out
at different times and so on
well it turns out i mean i
i should be able to quote more detail
but if you google this it'll all come up
so cicada there's a fungus which is not
a philosophy
it's called masospora is the fungus but
it makes
psilocybin and it makes cathinone which
is a stimulant compound
that's found in cot it's found it's the
stimulant found in cot
well masospora infects these cicadas
while they're in the ground and they
take it over and when they emerge out of
the ground
essentially their abdomen has been
replaced by
fungal sporangia right this is kind of a
grizzly tail
they emerge out of the ground and
instead of having
a butt basically
their tail is is replaced by these
massive spore masses
and
they're hyper sexual they try to mate
with anything that moves or even that
doesn't move
and they're waving around their butts
and spreading spores everywhere
infecting more cicadas and and this is
how the fungus effectively the fungus
has taken over the cicada and enslaved
it into a
[Music]
turn them into sex-crazed zombies if you
want to put it that way
also a good punk rock band
a sex-crazed zombie yes
yeah and this is this is actually known
in mycology there's another group of
fungi called the cordyceps yeah
cordyceps
same thing
i mean they don't use psilocybin but
they use
they infect something like an in an ant
or a caterpillar or many many kinds of
insects many kinds of species of
cordyceps and they effectively will take
over the insect's brain
and
direct its behavior for example in ants
there are certain kinds of ants the the
fungus will infect the ant
doesn't kill it but it causes it to
climb up a blade of grass
to the optimal position for spore
dispersal
then it kills it
then it will explode out of its head
with sporangia and the spores will
spread fall to the ground infect more
ants
so
effectively
these uh these cordyceps are are taking
over the behavior of the outs
maybe psilocybin is doing something like
that to us except they don't have to
infect our brain
we happen to like it so we consume it
but we are we're serving the
philosophy's
evil agenda which isn't so evil it
basically wants to reproduce and spread
nature has some crazy side choices out
there i mean
i pull crazy [ __ ] i pulled up i i pulled
up i just searched cicada psilocybin and
the first thing that pops up is an
article and the headline is these fungi
drug cicadas with psilocybin or
amphetamine to make the mate nonstop the
insects keep at it even if chunks of
their abdomens fall off
and the uh the fungus is apparently
masosporous sicadena i think it is i'm
probably mispronouncing that but there
are also cases you know mammalian cases
i can't recall the exact disease
i should actually be able to recall this
but it causes
rodents to become
suicidal in the sense that they become
aggressive towards cats and
effectively bait them yes and then the
cats eat the rats or the mice and
they contract this disease which then
has effects on cats i mean it just goes
on and on and on so nature's got a lot
going on uh suffice to say it's got a
lot going on and and from a standpoint
of like human ethics
this seems bizarre and crazy and and you
know act
actually evil but it's not it's just
this is nature nature and action and
things try to optimize their survival
strategies and for fungi
spreading and sporulating and all that
that's all they really want to do
that's what they want to do if you want
to attribute a
desire to them they're optimized for
reproduction and they'll do anything
they don't care if
they have to take over primates and
control look at look at how
psilocybin's
symbiosis philosophy symbiosis with
humans
has been beneficial for us right for
them and for the mushrooms because
everybody's growing them they're growing
them all over the place
yeah and that's true many plants and
fungi if you domesticate something
generally if humans domesticate a plant
or a fungus
that's like going on easy street for the
for the organism because we're here to
take care of it the plant has
domesticated the humans
until we blow up the planet completely
entirely but until then they have a
pretty good free ride about it
anyway
so let me ask you a question about a
comedy made in the
brotherhood of the screaming abyss about
lsd is a potential treatment for
dyslexia now i don't have all the
context but i pulled this out
and
this is uh it's going to lead to a
broader question about
perhaps unusual or unexpected
applications
or indications for psychedelics but this
this section here reads it did lead me
to speculate about the use of lsd as a
potential treatment for dyslexia we have
a limited understanding of
neuroplasticity to say nothing of how
psychedelics might affect it that man's
anecdote so of course i've omitted an
anecdote hints at the curious length
between psychedelics and language as do
the more prevalent accounts of
synesthesia i've discussed earlier
and then i'll actually read one more
sentence psychedelics have some
fundamental relationship to the way our
brains create meaning and understanding
out of sounds and images
i'm convinced that further
investigations into this phenomenon
would yield new
insights could you could you expand on
that because i
would agree certainly with the uh the
assertion of this fundamental
relationship
any thoughts on lsd specifically is
perhaps a a tool for addressing dyslexia
or or psychedelics for any other
indications that people might not guess
the connection to
lsd and language and i think even more
so with mushrooms because
you're probably familiar with an essay
i think by henry munn
that was published in a book called uh
i think it was by peter first called
hallucinogens and culture this was
around 1970. there's a wonderful chapter
in there called the mushrooms of
language it's by henry munn
and it makes the point and again like i
talk about this in the brotherhood of
the screaming abyss you
it makes the point that in this be
mushroom state
the poetry the language becomes much
more fluid it just sort of flows out of
you and that's why
these people can chant for
hours and and they're actually
instantiating
you know their the mushroom is speaking
through them
this gnosis literally this the logos is
the word the true
the pure logos actually flows through
them
and then there's the phenomenon of
synesthesia
which psychedelics especially mushrooms
can reliably do and you know i've the
association with meaningful images with
sound
some people
are naturally genetically synesthetic
and it's very often it's very
interesting how their
synthetic experiences
often have to do with words and numbers
and things like that and they'll say
things like well
the number 13 is chrome shaped and spiky
you know shiny and spiky what
but for them that's a reality
and i think you know i've argued that uh
mushrooms well i have terrance have lots
of people have
that mushrooms were important in the
origin of consciousness and i think that
it is this
this connection to language that
consciousness
depends
what we understand as true consciousness
depends on this
construction of this world view
essentially and that's built on language
this artificial reality that we
construct first for ourselves that's a
combination of
input
that is filtered and processed in a
certain way and
linked to associations memories all of
that kind of thing so we build this
what the neuroscientists now call the
default mode network which is kind of
ordinary creative consciousness
long before i heard of the default mode
network i was calling it the reality
hallucination
effectively we live in a hallucination
we live in an artificial world reality
that our brains construct
and
it must reflect
whatever is out there
because we're not wandering around
stepping in front of buses and things
like that so it does map to reality in
some ways but it's a it's actually an
impoverished version of reality what the
a lot of what the brain does
is filter things out you know and huxley
had this insight he talked about the
reducing valve
that to make the world comprehensible
you have to selectively filter
what gets in
and uh you're you inhabit this
filtered
you could almost use the word curated
version of reality
otherwise it would just be a blooming
buzzing confusion
and you wouldn't you wouldn't be able to
navigate
and then you can take a psychedelic you
can disable those mechanisms you can you
can disable this default mode
mechanism
open the gates of the reducing valve
and
that can be very beneficial
in terms of helping you get outside of
your reference frame
and that's very useful i think that
that's what psychedelics i think that's
where the therapeutic effect really
for many of the things it's indicated
for it's this ability to step outside
your reference frame temporarily and
look at your situation from a different
perspective
and but you wouldn't want to be there
all the time right because you wouldn't
be functional that's again why
you have to be very selective about your
sentence setting when you do these
things
it's a complex topic because i think it
does relate to the way
that we link images essentially internal
images to
sounds and
meaning effectively meaning
because
i'm here rapping to you right and i'm
making effectively small mouth noises
which are inherently meaningless
except that we happen to share a
language and so when i make these small
mouth noises
chances are your brain is reflecting it
in terms of
images
i say chair you see a chair i say star
you see a star so i mean it's more
complex than that but i think that's the
basis of
cognition really and if you look at
culture if you look at if you look at
consciousness it's all based on
this this relationship
between
sound
image and
and meaning or what they sometimes call
portentiousness
an ascribed meaning right it's a learned
association
that is not automatic right i think
about this a lot with
say infants and language and
i i'm sure there's someone who comment
on this much more intelligently than i
can but
when an infant let's say before they
develop full depth perception and so on
if they were to look at what's in front
of me they wouldn't see
laptop webcam
microphone
wood table etc
pile of papers as discrete objects until
they have
likely
at least not to that level of fidelity
until they have labels for those things
right it might just be
a flattened sort of two-dimensional
sheet of colors and shapes and shadows
and i think about that quite a bit also
as
uh you know you mentioned in the last
episode that you've
done
who knows how many sessions with
ayahuasca you know 500 plus and
it does seem that people develop or some
people develop an ability to discern and
see in those spaces in the same way that
an infinite sort of develops the ability
to
to discern between
these kind of discrete things that we
have labels for as adults if that makes
any sense at all i'm not sure if that
resonates at all
but i do think about that a lot and
i wanted to come back to something you
said which was uh you know adopting a
new reference point
and how that can be applied to many
different say conditions or issues and
in some ways you know a lot of the
outcomes that we see or even the case
studies that we might see in the case of
this person with dyslexia
or andy weil with his allergies right
sort of defy
conventional mechanistic explanations
for how that could happen right like as
far as i know lsd is not an
antihistamine right
so
so it raises all sorts of questions
and i wanted to read this this is going
to be uh
the last section that i wanted to read
to you and i i realized that the
brotherhood of the screaming abyss was
written quite a while ago so if if this
goes to a dead end i'll take the blame
for it but i i pulled this out which was
a segment on apollo 14.
it says this is another example of
reference point changes so apollo 14 is
mostly remembered for the two golf balls
that alan shepard hit with the makeshift
club he brought with him
it was also the mission on which and
this is the part that i bolded astra
edgar
mitchell i'm guessing that's how that
said had his famous savi kalpa samadhi
experience or mystical glimpse beyond
the self into the true nature of things
mitchell subsequently became interested
in consciousness research paranormal
phenomena such as esp and went on to
become a founder of the institute of
noetic sciences
uh or ions
what happened to edgar i don't actually
know this story
well i i think he had a mystical
experience basically and this was in
space while he was in orbit in space
yeah or on the moon whatever but i think
you know we know these things happen
spontaneously i think basically he he
got so far out of his reference frame
when who wouldn't be out of their
reference frame if they're on the moon
or in space right
and so he had a spontaneous mystical
experience you know we are all one with
the cosmos and all that and
now if he'd been on psychedelics at the
same time he might have really
but i i think that's what happens
and and so that that speaks to the
the idea that
that this ability to step literally
outside your box outside of this
default mode network is
probably
at the center of the psychedelic
experience at least in terms of
its therapeutic effect and it's it's
it's profundity if you will the
mystical experience or
however you want to describe that i mean
i mean roland griffiths and his people
even though they're the pioneers in
looking at psilocybin and mystical
experiences but they really
tone it down because they don't want to
alarm people you know
they don't talk about mystical
experiences anymore they talk about
personally meaningful experiences well
right that's nice but they're they're
mystical experiences damn it i mean they
are
they are experiences of transcendence
and it's important i think to
to acknowledge that
oh i agree i mean they did also develop
you know the
i'm probably getting the terminology
wrong but the sort of mystical
experience questionnaire which had
the parameters and characteristics which
include ineffability and so on right
right and some people just get this
naturally i mean for example albert
hoffman
i mean albert hoffman
had
numerous uh what you might call
quasi or actual mystical experiences in
nature
long before he took lsd
i did not know that he was a person who
was able to do this and it was very
meaningful for him yeah
and so for people who don't have any
context albert hoffman
the first to synthesize i guess lsd 25
it was at the that was the one that got
him off yes he still that was the one
that he was called to take before he
went on his bike ride
that's right that's right
yeah
uh there's a wonderful book i i should
okay i should mention
i like to plug books i guess others have
written you've probably read it called
bicycle day by brian blomerth
i've heard of it i haven't read it it's
a uh graphic novel it's a graphic comic
novel about his discovery of lsd
i i wrote the forward then oh amazing
it's a great book people should bicycle
day all right so bicycle day we'll we'll
link to that in the in the show notes i
also want to mention a book
that is related to a word and a concept
and an experience a phenomena or
phenomenon i guess that it's really a
set of phenomena
synesthesia so there are two resources i
want to recommend the first is a book
that i first bought in
i want to say late high school called
the mind of a neminist
so the mind of as in mnemonic device the
mind of a demonist a little book about a
vast memory and it's written by a.r
luria
or maybe it's with a forward by uh yeah
jerome s bruner written by a.r luria but
it's it's effectively a case study of
a rain man like figure who experiences
regularly experiences synesthesia so
this intermingling of the senses
so as you mentioned kind of
identifying numbers as shapes or
smelling colors
having tastes associated with musical
notes or sounds things like this which
can be either
and in some cases both
an enormous blessing or
the
most difficult curse
yeah if it is something that you can't
turn off
that's one there's also a i want to say
a documentary or may have been a tv
series called brain man
about
uh
young brit at least at the time was
young who experiences or claims to
experience
synesthesia as i understand it
also fairly controversial daniel tamet
is the figure in this one
but
still makes for a fascinating
a fascinating watch and i think it's kim
peak the actual basis for rain man who
is also featured in that book
who
believe it or not can read
two pages at the same time one with each
eye
so try to try that at home and see how
far you get
but those are two points on synesthesia
what i'd love to ask you about now is
espd55 so we should probably
also provide some context maybe you can
do this what espd stands for in just a
bit of the histories for those who don't
have it and didn't hear the first
conversation
and then
i would love to
hear you
describe some of what is going to be
discussed
the why to do it etc sure
because as you know i have a collection
of these sort of historical anthologies
already
espd is stands for
ethno-pharmacologic
search for psychoactive drugs
and in 1967 the national institute of
mental health sponsored
a conference in san francisco by that
name and it was a closed conference
the only thing the taxpayers ever got
out of it was this book that they
published the proceedings of the
conference well somehow or other
that came on to my radar at the age of
18
and
the next year the year after the
conference was done it was somehow i got
it and it opened up the world for me of
ethnopharmacology well the government
staged this conference published this
book they were supposed to have
follow-up
events every 10 years or so to keep
abreast of what was going on in the
field
well that never happened
the
the war on drugs came along they
that were embarrassed basically they'd
never done anything even though you
could order it from the us government
printing office for many years well so i
always wanted to stage a follow-up and
50 years went by
circumstances never allowed that to
happen but in 2017 everything came
together
i had funding i had a place i had people
to help me organize it
and you know i want to give a shout out
to them because
it wasn't me that did it i had a lot of
help
some of them and so we did this this
conference in 2017 we did
espd50 this commemorative 50th
anniversary conference
and
we uh we published the original
67 volume together with the 2017 volume
as a box set we put the videos on
the videos are still up there people can
watch them and so now it's been five
years so we decided to do a five-year
follow-up
god knows if i'll be here in 10 years so
you know we decided to do a five-year
follow-up and that's what espd55
is the five year from the 2017
conference or the 55th year of the first
conference
and
that's the origin that's the whole idea
of it the 2017 conference was pretty
much focused on ethnopharmacology and
sort of the unexplored
dark corners or you know fringes of
ethnopharmacology in other words the
ideas that search for psychoactive drugs
it's a quest
we're doing that this year we have some
really interesting topics we have for
example one
person that's presented on
psychedelics found in sponges and you
know marine sponges and that sort of
thing
but we've also got a couple forums we
have three forums that don't really fit
into this pattern one of them
is
a forum on coca
and they need to destigmatize coca so
we've got
coke is a wonderful medicine as coca not
as cocaine is horrible cocaine is a
horrible drug but coca
is beneficial and coca
is
just at the center of andean traditions
and medicine and all that
and potentially could be as a
nutraceutical as an herbal medicine it
could be very beneficial and
there are all sorts of aspects because
you give the people who grow it who
formerly were basically just told
by the cartels okay you work for us now
if you don't produce it we'll just kill
you
but give those
families mostly economic benefits and
bring coca back as a as a respected
medicine so we've got wade davis
participating in this we've got andy
weil they're both of them long time
advocates of of coca as a medicine and a
food actually which it also is it's very
nutritionally beneficial
and i want to take a second just to
get into
some of the logistics of espd55 as a
sidebar i'll just say the box set of
books for espd50
you can find online you can find them on
amazon they're beautifully done
i have them on my bookshelf absolutely
a joy to read
for espd55 people can find that at
espd55.com i'll put that in the show
notes and people can
either attend in person in the uk may
23-26 this is 2022 or they can attend
online are those the the two primary
options that are available for folks
yes that's right and less less and less
in person because because it's rapidly
filling up basically the in person but
we intend to live stream it and when we
did the espd50 we had at times we had 75
000 people
participating we hope to meet or exceed
that benchmark this time and uh
there will be another book there'll be
another there'll be a book that comes
out of it only one this time but it'll
be
also high quality and it will match the
[Music]
you know the design and everything to
the previous one so it'll look good on
your shelf
and the person that just that provided
the art that
amazing lovely watercolors that were
incorporated into the design she
is there's a link to her website she's
selling
prints essentially print prints uh
print sets of about i think
about a hundred of her illustrations
that people can order if they wish and
they're beautiful so
so dennis one thing i'd like to do to to
sell this event if it's okay with you
and we can cut this out if it ends up
being more than you'd like to reveal but
i just want to give some teasers for
folks i'm not going to give away too
much
or i won't give a lot of the specifics
but let me just give some other samples
of sessions is that okay with you dennis
sure
okay so there's a session on kratom a
lot of people have questions about
kratom metro john espiciosa if i'm
pronouncing the correctly mature giant
fascinating fascinating plant
i'm going to put this in a little
gingerbread trail so i'm not going to
fill in all the gaps but a road map for
sustainable development of ayahuasca
production in the amazon lowlands great
interest to me
yes psychedelic fauna so to be
distinguished from flora i'll just put
that
i'll leave that alone i won't go into
that too much here's another
history of psychoactive plants and fungi
in chinese medicine something you do not
hear in
at least much that i have at all in
mainstream conversations
you mentioned
marine sponges
yield enhancing lessons from silicon
which is what psilocybin is but quickly
metabolized into
uh in the human body i guess that's
probably what
maybe first pass metabolism through the
liver
we've got hunting medicines among the
matsi genka the harpy's gift to the
jaguar's curse
great title
watchuma
the sort of phytochemical profiling
watchuma some people might know that as
san pedro cactus
also very interesting to me personally
from a
from a
conservation and sustainability
perspective because it grows so much
faster than say peyote
which is endangered very very endangered
added in anthro
so i'm going to leave that alone but if
people have never heard that word a it's
a lot of syllables b
fascinating history
i mean there is contemporary use but
that's kind of beyond the scope of of
what we're talking about right this
second
establishing collections of sacred
psychoactive medicinal plants at
wasawaska that's in floripa
you have some amazing speakers i can
just say not as as the leading expert in
this field but as someone who is
certainly an avid consumer and
spectator tourist
do read a lot you have an outstanding
roster of speakers here's one you don't
see every day chemically induced
otherworldly experiences of zoroastrians
in iran i mean
yes please would love to be part of that
incredible i mean where else are you
going to find that answer is probably
nowhere
and it just goes on and on and on so
i'll leave it at that there i i didn't
even i i didn't even cover
50 of it so there's there's a lot here
and there's there are many documentaries
you have people who are very well known
we didn't get into his resume at all but
wade davis certainly
who's known for his books
yeah paul stamets
yeah i mean the whole idea
of the espd conferences is that
they're out of the box in a certain way
it's not just the same stuff i mean i'm
happy that there are all these
virtual uh meetings about the
therapeutic uses of uh psilocybin and
in ptsd and
and addiction i mean that's important
stuff but there's a lot of duplication
in some of these things we want to
we want to kind of stake out an area and
look into the obscure
corners but still important
and and kind of highlight the
the work that remains to be done for
example the watchuma project is very
interesting
and and i can claim a little bit of
credit for it the person that's going to
present there primarily
is
a student of wave davises actually in at
ubc she's in the phd program and then
her partner and colleague a
peruvian gentleman
joseph
i forget his last name sorry but they've
collaborated on this
and
when i
was asked to be on laurel uh
uh laurel's laurel sugden is her name
asked to be on her committee i
asked them if they
asked her if she was interested in in
the chemistry side of this the
ethno-pharmacology side of it not just
the ethnography and she
indicated that she was that this was
interesting to her
so we
we hooked up with a
investigator at the albany college of
pharmacy who's developed an innovative
way
to
non-invasive way to sample plants and
and create you know do uh like
phytochemical fingerprints essentially a
quick way to look at the variation in
the different varieties and species of
this cactus and then using mass
spectrometry and other fancy tools
actually do a like a phytochemical
fingerprint of these different
varieties and so on so it's going to be
a very interesting
presentation that combines ethnography
chemistry and pharmacology
yeah and there's others like that
michael is going to talk about uh his
work with the
with the cultural keystone species
michael cohen
and uh
and then as you mentioned the people
from icers we've got two
two people from icers that are talking
about the whole issues related to
the
unintended consequences of ayahuasca
tourism basically yeah depletion of the
species
and all of that and
how do we address that so
i think it's going to be a stimulating
conference
you know it's going to be
it's going to be long
so let me ask you this this might seem
like a strange turn but
i want to ask you about
life
and death for a second because you you
made a you cracked a joke earlier i'm
not sure if it was totally unjust or
serious but you said i don't know if
i'll be around here in 10 years so we're
going to do the fifth year new edition
if you're open to talking about i mean
how do you relate to
death and mortality how do you how do
you think about that relate to it
in in any way you'd like to take a stab
at that
if there's anything to to be discussed
well
i relate to it in the sense that
everybody has to die sooner or later
everybody crosses that threshold sooner
or later
and a lot of
religious traditions and philosophical
traditions and everything have to do
with the focus on what happens after you
die
you know or when you die
and but
from a scientific perspective
i think the the only answer the only
honest answer is nobody knows what
happens when you die when you really die
there's lots of studies about the near
death experience and all the changes
that happens during the near-death
experience
fact is that's not death
you know so that is maybe a reflection
of the
the stuff that happens to your brain
while you're in the process of dying but
it is not in fact dying
is there anything
that persists after death
the honest answer
i feel is i just don't know
i'm open to the possibility
i hope there is and but maybe not it's a
case of
be careful what you wish for right i
mean like shakespeare said in that sleep
of death what dreams may come
hopefully they'll be pleasant if there
is something or hopefully
if there is something after death
hopefully there will be something
worthwhile experiencing and not just
terrible or if there's nothing after
death if there's just oblivion
well
i won't be around to worry about it
so either way i'm okay with i don't plan
to check out soon i hope not i want to
be around for
espd 60 and 65 and 70. but let's face it
i'm i'm
no spring chicken i'm getting up there
so you know i'm 71 i'll be 72 later this
year so
not real old but not real young neither
so yeah
i think what i do is i think that
i i kind of take a leaf from the people
for example that gets psilocybin for end
of life therapy you know
very often the
insight that they get from that is well
yes i'm dying but i'm alive now
and i'm sort of that's where i'm at
i mean we're all dying tim slowly fast
for sure whatever
important thing is we're alive now
make the most of it
that's what i think
so do you certainly seem to be making
the most of it
what are you most excited about right
now
while you are alive which you are like
what is giving you the most
joy and aliveness these days could be
anything
i think a lot of us are
really concerned with things that are
happening and
the future looks pretty grim
in a lot of ways
but you do what you can i i think that
giving into despair
is not a solution for anything
and it's tempting you could just say
things are so bad
that there is no hope but then
if you come to that point
then there really isn't any hope so you
just keep plugging
and to the degree that i can i keep
plugging and i've got
many people
who
feel the same way
does any of it make any difference i
don't know
but like the biognosis project is
a good example
if we can slow down this
this disappearance of knowledge and
the
disappearance of the habitats and the
loss of species and all that just a
little bit i mean compared to
what other groups and organizations are
doing probably biognosis is a small
thing
but it's it's our thing it's what we're
doing and i think
maybe it'll make a little difference
so let me spell that for people so
bionosis just so we all have the
spelling it's b i o g n o s i s yes a
made-up word right biology bio-life and
gnosis knowledge knowledge a coined word
really yeah but that that's the idea and
people can find more about bionosis
bridges to ancestral wisdom at
bionosis.mckenna dot academy and we'll
link to that
in
the show notes as well let me come back
to a second for
kind of slowing
the
degradation and depletion of our
natural habitat
this this
sort of greenish blue marble
that is spinning through space with a
bunch of monkeys on it
who are making a whole
mess
busy making a whole mess of it
what is your current perspective on say
synthetic options for
psychedelic compounds in the sense that
i found an older interview where you
were interviewed by
nailed magazine
and
there was a bit of a discussion about
you know synthetic freeze-dried
ayahuasca and you mentioned how
and feel free to revise this but how you
felt that it's it may be a psychedelic
but it's not ayahuasca because the
ayahuasca experience begins when you
taste it and the purging is potentially
a feature and not a bug and
i'd just be curious to know let's say in
the case of ayahuasca
what do you think some of the most
viable solutions might be to
avoiding over harvesting
and endangering these various plant
species is the
synthetic route you know creating
pharmawaska alternatives
viable attractive
unappealing
ill-fated what's what's your perspective
i think we have to look at all
all viable solutions
for example
psilocybins psilocybin mushrooms don't
really have that issue
i mean they're not endangered right they
can be grown by megatons so
so we're not going to run out of
psilocybin and maybe if we want to go
with natural psychedelics maybe we
should emphasize those
there is a lot of global interest in
psilocybin
and ayahuasca is endangered and and
peyote certainly is endangered and
things like eboga are in danger the
verge of extinction on the verge of
extinction and i think part of the
solution is
number one i think the community the
psychedelic community to the degree that
there is one
really has to step up and be responsible
and i i think that the community
should seek consensus for example peyote
is a good example the community
like these decrim movements that are
happening across the country and in
other countries and so on in general i'm
in favor of them
but the indigenous people have asked
don't decriminalize peyote
let it be our thing well i disagree with
not
decriminalizing it because fundamentally
i think no no plan no organism
should be criminalized i think the very
ideas is repulsive to me
but that said the community can say
let's not criminalize it but let's
protect it and let's
develop a
community consensus that okay
we'll just
put peyote behind defense we'll say it's
the indigenous people's thing we will
not encourage on that we'll respect that
and we'll avoid
using peyote
some of these other things watchuma for
example watchuma is a good source it's
not endangered yet it's much more
abundant it's easier to grow
that's a good alternative
we're at a point with watchuma where we
can
use it responsibly if we don't then it
too may become endangered eventually
ayahuasca is a very tricky one
i think that pharmawask is fine but it's
not ayahuasca it may have uses and
that's
it's a different drug it's it's
completely different and i have nothing
against synthetics you know i think
synthetics have their place and
like i like to tell people synthetics
are
they're made by all natural organic
chemists right so they come from nature
ultimately
yeah but
what i would like to see happen if if it
could is developing a
you know over time developing
relationships with indigenous
communities
to produce
medicines like ayahuasca but not
encourage people to go to south america
to take ayahuasca
encourage these communities to produce
them and
and take the medicine to the people
rather than people to the medicine
develop ways that are legal to export
them
to north america europe and so on and
through decrim establish centers where
people can come and have these
psychedelic experiences that are legal
and safe and well structured and all
that
and
give benefits
back to the people who produce it who
grow it economically
economic benefits but kind of avoid the
disruption of the culture that happens
when all these rich gringos come down
there
to take ayahuasca and i mean i'm guilty
i've
organized lots of ayahuasca retreats
i mean i've seen tremendous benefits for
people that come to those retreats
but i've kind of evolved in my view of
it whether that is a actually a good
thing
yeah it is and it isn't and that's why
decrim is important but i think decrim
has got to be
very uh
thoughtful
and clear
in in its approach to this and say well
you know we're not going to encroach on
things like iboga
and ayahuasca
or or do it in this way bring bring the
medicines north rather than the people
south
and that would transform communities as
well both in both places so that's kind
of
this is not something that's going to
happen
next week or next year this will take a
decade or more and it depends on how the
laws can be
can be changed
yeah i i i would something simple about
this
there's nothing simple there's nothing
simple and i want to ask you a number of
questions about the psychedelic
community as it were with community and
quotation marks perhaps but before i get
to that i want to take maybe
not not exactly a counterpoint but just
to
add my perspective on peyote for a
moment which is
you know i believe that it's it's
effectively inevitable that peyote is
going to go extinct even with
current demand by
members of the native american church
and
very constrained
production and distribution and also a
lot of poaching
yeah
they're really only a handful of
licensed you know people who can
distribute and there are abuses of the
system even within
these these various kind of distribution
channels
i i really do feel strongly that this is
one of the last
shreds of
let's just call it culture though it's
not true that peyote was widely
distributed prior to quanah parker and
and right other figures and initiatives
but
it is it is so important to so many
north american indigenous
people that i i and and also i'm guilty
in the sense that like i have had
experiences with peyote i've been
invited by
by the the people
who are traveling through the proper
channels and nonetheless
spending time with
a little bit of time not a ton but a
little bit of time with the board of the
uh indigenous peyote conservation
initiative
it's a sad picture when you really look
at it and you consider that you know
these these indigenous groups generally
are not going to want to consume peyote
that is
cultivated in greenhouses they're
almost certainly not going to be open to
synthetic mescaline or san pedro
and just
let them have it is my feeling and if if
a way to
hedge against sort of
bad or chaotic
communal behavior is by
leaving that one regulated in the way
that it's regulated
i'm okay with that uh just because there
are alternatives
for people who are poor seeking some
type of mescaline or mescaline
you like analog experience but that said
tim
i mean i agree with all that but what is
really wrong with cultivated peyote
yeah why can't they see that as a viable
part of the solution not the whole
solution it doesn't have to be wild
yeah i mean the the reasons
that they're prejudiced against it
or that they don't want to use it is
they're they're spiritual reasons
they're not
scientific or cultural reasons they
could adapt
they could adapt
to
cultivated greenhouse even tissue
culture
these kinds of things they could adapt
to it
but
there has to be a little bit of
give on both sides
for this
solution i hear you yeah i hear you i
guess
i i'll just and again uh certainly i
wish we had some
sort of indigenous representation here
to hear their perspective it is as you
as as far as i understand largely a
spiritual
matter a sort of a cosmo vision yeah
facet of the belief system and if it's
not coming out of the ground there are
there are ramifications and that
peyote
derived from the greenhouse is not the
same etc but i guess my perspective is
there are so many battles to be fought
this one's a pretty easy give
just let them have it just let them have
it like if you're
if you live in venice and you do like
you're like into the yoga oscar scene
and you have your green juice and you
want to experience mesclun don't do
peyote just use something else
i don't have it i'm all for it but even
if you let them have it
it's still on the way out i mean they'll
still have the problem of the poachers
and yeah they do it's a mess it's
amazing it's it's really a mess and it's
a shame
because it doesn't have to happen
i've spent time with a few
i don't know if they'd be considered
botanists but certainly scientists oh my
god i wish i could remember one he was a
fascinating character lived in alpine
texas he spent
decades studying
le fafra williamsi i guess it is and
knows just the ins and outs of of
cultivation also but even if you were to
have greenhouses right
how long does it take to cultivate even
if you have the most advanced
hydroponics or whatever you might use to
accelerate the growth process what are
we talking 10 years to grow a mature
button i mean yeah and in some cases 15
20. i mean so even with greenhouses
you're facing
incredible constraints on volume
so there is that so let's let's talk
about this if you're open to it if if
you want to add something please jump in
well it's tough i mean there's there's
just no optimal solution for peyote and
we're very impatient we're a very
impatient species i mean would the
indigenous people have the insight or
the patience to say
let's just leave
let's just stop for 10 years and work on
developing the
wild populations i mean and who's going
to administer that and who's going to
make those decisions yeah it's just one
of those things where
it's hard to find consensus everybody's
got a different idea and we have a hard
time listening to each other so so i
wanted to
i mean this is maybe a better
conversation for like a few glasses of
wine or a few bottles of wine but let me
let me
throw this out there so the psychedelic
community and i put in quotation marks
earlier
it's like maybe i'm just cantankerous
and didn't get enough sleep last night
but
the psychedelic community or many
components of it drive me absolutely
[ __ ] bananas and
i feel like i feel like it should be
called the psychedelic infighting
olympics because
if you if you want proof that
psychedelics do not automatically create
a kumbaya
world peace
world of collaboration like you need not
look very far you just look at all of
the infighting and
kind of mutual crippling
in this
space and it is
astonishing it is it is just
astonishing to see and
part of the reason this this comes up
for me
a because i'm kind of immersed in it as
as as many people are as you are
and it's so bad that i'm thinking about
taking a little hiatus myself because
it's it's so demoralizing for me to see
the just absolute lack
and this is not across the board there
are many great people there are many
people who are clear ethical
effective but then they're surrounded
for every one of those i feel like
they're just 10 idiots running around
like chickens with their heads cut off
swinging machetes at everybody
and
this relates to
a section in
the brotherhood of the screaming abyss
so let me read something and
maybe we can
i'll let you grab the baton so here it
goes in many ways the diggers tried to
actualize the best ideals of hippiedom
like most utopian communities however
they found it difficult to make reality
fit with the ideal inevitably they seem
to found her on the recalcitrance of
human nature for every idealist who is
ready to pitch in and work for the
common good there is an opportunist who
wants something for nothing or worse to
grab power and bend it to his or her own
ends and then dot dot dot dot
you know trying to run an egalitarian
community in a dense city is a challenge
under the best of circumstances and
here's the part i i highlighted for
myself and and every community that
aspires to be spontaneous to thrive
without leaders or hierarchies must
confront the vacuum it creates for the
power crazed
yeah
i think that describes where we are
today in so many
different micro communities
within the psychedelic
larger quotation mark
community end quotation
yeah
maybe you can just talk me off the ledge
i i think that we're monkeys tim
ultimately we're monkeys and monkeys
squabble and monkeys look for
opportunities and
you could look at any spiritual practice
or any church
eastern religion ashrams all of that
i think any time they're dealing with a
spiritually powerful
technology
which psychedelics are or other
religious practices are
communion in the catholic church
meditation and yoga in in eastern
traditions
these can also be
used to
control people to to control people's
behavior and and in that context there's
always some
power mad person almost always a male
who
sees an opportunity to
seize the
the levers of power to their own good
and it's usually the motivations are
i mean so boring
and so disappointing but basically
they're usually the same thing it's
usually about the chicks and the money i
mean i'm sorry
but that's what it's about right
and people are motivated by those things
and this idea that uh it's very scarface
yeah effectively yeah that psychedelics
are gonna dissolve the ego and turn us
all into bodhisattvas and we'll all be
kind and harmonious to each other it's
just not gonna happen
i mean it could but we have to evolve
into it it seems like and and
you have to
be sincere about it there are always
people
who are looking
for an opportunity to exercise power of
one sort or another financial
social or otherwise and psychedelics are
not immune to this you and i know i know
lots of people who take lots of
psychedelics
they're still [ __ ]
it's not a cure for that you know
it can
help you
again step out of your reference frame
and look at your situation you may have
a revelation and say oh god i really am
an [ __ ] i need to change my
my whole
behavior
many people are not interested in
changing because
so frankly i don't know what to what to
say what the solutions are it all has to
do with where the moral compass comes
from you have to have
some kind of an ethical framework that
you
work out of and that has to involve
you know
empathy i think is a big factor and
just respect for
other humans
and it can be
it's rare i mean and i think
psychedelics can be effective tools for
learning this but if you're a sociopath
it's probably not going to help you i
mean
shaman i respected very much i asked him
who would he not give
ayahuasca to
and he said well then basically there
are two kind two kinds of people that i
would never give it to one is
schizophrenics
because
it's not going to help them and the
other is sociopaths because it's not
going to help them either
i would go so far as to say you could
probably make both of those worse right
the schizophrenic certainly
like throw them again dash them up on
the rocks of chaos and then the
sociopath might just come back and say i
just need to do 10 times more than of
what i'm currently doing
or they come back with some messianic
delusions exactly that i have to save
the world you know
i alone can fix it
yeah it's
something we have to evolve beyond i
think that
psychedelics are our
co-evolutionary partners i think that
they help us become
better people
but
it's not
you have to work at it right like any
kind of spiritual
moral ethical development
it just doesn't
you're not going to make it unless you
actually
try
and believe in it and nobody succeeds a
hundred percent i mean there are plenty
of bad things about me that's for sure
that i don't share with everybody but i
know what they are
you know and
and it's just tough it's just tough to
be a kind and gentle and an insightful
and wise person
that's kind of what we're here for
though i think yeah
yeah what a world so discouraging right
well it's discouraging i mean a part of
me wonders because i'm still
all things considered even though i've
been
you know very involved for the last
whatever six to eight years kind of
publicly
new to the scene and i wonder you know
of the
of the more senior guard
if you're looking at everything that's
happening and you're optimistic if
you're like if you look at it and you're
saying well yeah a lot of shitty stuff
is happening but like we've seen this
before it'll shake out and hopefully we
won't have the executive order to put
everything back on schedule one and shut
everything down which
is not an impossibility right
and nor is it is it a solution
no
that's not a solution
i think we get caught up in the dynamics
of the of the moment too i think we have
to
step away take the 30 000 foot level
perspective and realize that these
things are really
co-evolutionary partners and we've been
co-evolving with them well pick your
time maybe for a couple million years
you know if we believe
the stone date theory which i do
basically i i think it's credible i mean
we don't need to get into that but for a
long long time we have co-evolved in
effectively in symbiosis with these
plants and they've been sort of nudging
us along on this very difficult path
we're midway between the apes and the
angels right now you know we haven't
reached
haven't reached the angelhood yet we're
still suspended
but slowly but the thing is these these
dynamics these are really biological
processes and they they play themselves
out over millennia of time
so
what's going to happen in the next 10
years the next 50 years
that's a very small slice of time i feel
that we're always going to have
the relationship with these plants
as long as number one we don't drive
them into extinction number two we don't
drive ourselves into extinction
all of these caveats but hopefully
they will be around for us to learn from
and boy do we have to learn we have a
lot to learn still yeah it's a slow
process
so let me ask you just a few more
questions dennis and then we can we can
also cover anything you'd like to cover
that i haven't brought up
but let me ask you because i don't think
i asked you last time
if you could only have two and this may
not be the right adjective so we can
change the question but if you could
only have
two psychoactive
plants slash substances
for the rest of your life
what would you choose and i'm gonna i'm
gonna make a few allowances here so
number one you can have caffeine
caffeine's a freebie you get that okay
so you don't have to go all right
so you don't have to pick that
and then for the sake of simplicity
we'll consider
common
cocktails let's just say like ayahuasca
we'll consider that a single plant
yeah
this can include synthetics it could
certainly include things from the
the natural kingdoms
which which two would you choose
so i only get to choose two that's right
we could start with three if that's
easier and then we will pair it down to
two i like to
i enjoy asking people this question no i
think mushrooms would definitely be one
one of those
and uh
i think cannabis would be one
which i don't use as much now as i used
to but i do
i do use it i think of it as a
beneficial
very beneficial plant ally
and uh
now just in terms of my current state of
health and all i think those two
uh ayahuasca would would probably i'd
like to also have access to ayahuasca
would you find the benefits of cannabis
to be for you or what are the the ways
in which you use it
i think it just reduces stress it helps
me relax it helps me
sleep and calm down and and it's good
for insight i think it's good for
writing for example
just a general
bomb
to the spirit in a sense b-a-l-m that
kind of thing
nurturing
my brother used to call cannabis sister
mary redemptress
and it's that's kind of like that you
know it's kind of like that
this benevolent loving
feminine
medicine
and do you uh do you typically smoke is
that
your preferred means of
consumption
it has been yeah yeah
i have tried vaping i've tried
edibles neither one of those works for
me
but my cardiologist i now have heart
conditions that i have to worry about so
my cardiologist said don't smoke
whatever you do you know and i i no
matter how much no matter what you're
smoking at night so i tried that for a
while and finally i decided i tried
vaping and that was actually
harder on my heart than it was smoking
so what i do is i smoke
tiny amounts
in one of those cigarette looking things
and yeah seems to work
i mean it's sort of like i told my
cardiologist i said well yeah i can
avoid all these things but you know i
have to live right i mean if if i die
smoking cannabis okay so be it you know
i'm at peace with that
do you have a any preferred
uh i'm not even i'm no cannabis expert
are you preferred strain anything along
those lines
no not really i'm i'm from an era where
long before any of that made sense
if it's cannabis if it's work if it
works i'm fine with it
you know i i will say
that
i've only in the last few years really
had proper exposure to cannabis which
took a while to unpack what the hell i
mean by that but i have a few novice
takeaways are number one
i'm actually really glad i discovered it
very
relatively late in life because
it could have been a real problem for me
i can tell
and
number two the
the two aspects you know three aspects
that have most impressed me are number
one the effects on sleep
although
it seems like you need to be careful so
that you're not eliminating your rem
cycles entirely so it seems like you can
certainly overdo it
but just in terms of turning down the
the volume and speed of mental chatter
yes so that i can sleep it's it's quite
remarkable
the second is
how
intensely it
impr seems to improve again i mean who
knows if someone were observing it they
might have a different perspective but
uh how intensely it affects and
sensitizes
my
perception of music and production of
music say with percussion
unlike anything else without
i suppose of course the dose makes the
poison but at reasonable doses without
the distortion that might accompany even
moderate say psilocybin use and the
third is
how [ __ ] strong cannabis is now i
mean compared to like the few puffs i
had in high school
i had two puffs with a friend recently
and i laid down on my bed thought i was
gonna have to skip dinner
and had full-blown visuals for a good
hour i mean it was
i could not believe
how
psychedelic the experience was
compared to many things that get lumped
in under the umbrella of psychedelics
like mdma which i don't consider a
psychedelic but my experience with
really strong cannabis certainly
i would say i'd be curious to hear your
perspective would line up nicely with
some of the descriptions of psychedelic
experience
how do you think about that
yeah i don't think of cannabis as a
psychedelic either really
for also for one thing pharmacologically
it certainly isn't but i think with all
these super strong strains that are
available
you can get there
more than before i mean i've had it
before before they had strong cannabis
there was hashish which was always
a favorite and you can get some pretty
psychedelic places especially if you eat
ash
about now people are having cannabis
ceremonies and they're effectively
psychedelic ceremonies they're like
ayahuasca sessions and i haven't been to
any actually but
but people do it in a pair and that's
kind of interesting because here is a
legal pretty much legal medicine that
people can use that way i'm
i'm
in favor of it i think it's i think it's
beneficial and there's no legal risk and
and yeah these strains are out there
thanks to modern genetics mostly
so i saw just a couple things so on the
legal side definitely check your local
jurisdiction
with listeners around the world so
check your local restrictions or laws
around these things
and i i will also just add because we're
talking about a lot of compounds a lot
of different uses
that
i haven't touched anything in at least
three months right so it's not like i'm
walking around with a fanny pack full of
drugs all day hitting something every
two to three hours i haven't touched
anything except for a few glasses of
wine in the last
three months
so
you should also i would say as a
not to be too like pedantic and
yes dad thanks for the advice but i i
think i think it is important and
helpful to abstain for periods of time
for at least the purpose of proving to
yourself that you can do it yeah i mean
that's my perspective
dennis is there anything else you would
like to
mention
like to
comment on or add before we begin to to
wind down this conversation
well a couple of things i mean we have
pretty well covered the basis tim this
has been great you've
you're very kind to spend so much time
on this but uh one thing i'd like to
mention you've quoted a number of times
from the brotherhood of the screaming
abyss
people may be interested to know that
there'll be a second edition coming out
toward the end of the year oh no kidding
i had no idea yeah they're gonna reprint
it i've written a new chapter so it'll
be the old one but i've written a new
forward and a new chapter for it
and sort of
in that sense tried to bring it up to
date because the book itself
what it actually described ended in
more or less with my brother's death in
2000 and then the book itself was
published in 2012 well a lot has
happened in the last 22 years
so uh so it's coming out synergetic is
gonna reprint it and it'll have this
this amended chapter to it so that's one
thing
the other thing that
we
didn't really get into
and maybe
when we talked about biognosis i don't
know if people understand
exactly what we're doing but in a
nutshell what we're trying to do with
this biognosis project
which is a long-term project and it's
actually going to cost
considerable money if we if we do it
right
basically two aspects to it in terms of
this
knowledge recovery knowledge
preservation and connection into science
one is doing
this series of documentaries
on amazonian traditional medicine
the first documentary where we have a
short they'll be short documentaries the
first one
will be showing that espd55
and
making a big
pitch basically for support to
make the
you know complete the series we can see
this as five
to seven
thirty to forty minute documentaries
that kind of is a snapshot of
traditional medicine as it exists today
in the 21st century in the amazon and
that's one aspect to it but then linked
to that is this much bigger long-term
project has to do with the herbarium in
aquitos at the university in the ketos
and
and digitizing the herbarium
it's got 100
000 specimens only
half those have actually been mounted
but what we want to do is make
high-resolution scans of those specimens
put them online in an accessible
database that anyone can access and we
actually have a an idea for creating a
vr
using vr and
mai technology to build
what we're calling the visionary
rainforest
which would be basically
[Music]
these collections distributed through
this
this virtual space
and
just as a way of representing so people
if they can't go to the amazon they
could immerse themselves in the
visionary rainforest
but it wouldn't be just a
it would it would actually have
information each of the collections
from the herbarium would be assigned to
a place because they were collected
someplace right so you go into this
virtual environment and they'll be nodes
that represent
each collection you can click on a node
and that will open up a whole
link to many forms of information
maybe information about traditional uses
about chemistry about genomics about
all kinds of things so make this a
dynamic
experienceable environment but make it
have scientific validity
as well
so this is a grand vision and hopefully
again it will be a resource for anyone
for scientists especially but really
anyone
that wants to uh
you know
experience
the
[Music]
i mean the herbarium in the ketosis is
kind of a run-down
gradually
eroding
situation
but it's a gem it's an important
resource all these plants are there
160 000 plus
specimens yeah about 100 thousand
specimens altogether yeah and so we want
to make that a real thing and turn it
into a world-class resource for and the
whole idea of this is
i think it was uh ralph waldo emerson is
the one who said a
weed is a plant
whose virtues haven't yet been
discovered
in that sense every plant is valuable
and to the extent that we can link
information about these collections to
to them that gives them a value
and
i mean they don't need validation they
don't need value from us to be valuable
but it gives them a value that we
recognize so we're gonna
talk about this
this project
and it's going to involve working
very closely with the university there
and they're all on board for it
it's probably going to cost several
million dollars to do this
but
i think we can get the money i think
that people will see the value of it and
step up and do it
and this is just
in the overall scheme of things it's
just one little thing we can do to try
to slow down what's happening in the
amazon because the amazon is
the amazon is on fire
along with the rest of the world and
it's going to go away it will be lost
forever if we don't do something about
it in the next
decade or so and by we i mean humanity
we're just
our little academy and our little
project is a small part of it but maybe
enough of a part of it to
be a
a catalyst in this
i think that pretty much summarizes it
that this biognosis thing in terms of
the nuts and bolts are these two
components one is using videography
to document and preserve this knowledge
and make it compelling for people
we want to do a netflix series or
national geographic whoever will
take a look at it and we want it to be
something that people want to watch
and then this other project is
is obviously not separate from it but
but is a
longer term and more ambitious thing of
creating this
virtual this visual rain for a visionary
rainforest that will live
on the web and be accessible to people
and benefit
you know the people in the amazon and
people worldwide that are interested in
in these amazonian plants
so that's that's the basic idea
and people can find more on bionosis and
i will include this link along with
links to everything else in the show
notes for folks bionosis
biognosis.mckenna
mckenna dot academy and i'm sure if you
just search bionosis mckenna on google
that it'll pop right up
and i encourage people also
to check out
espd55.com another link that i'll
include if the
last two volumes are any indication and
if the schedule
is any indication
this should be a fantastic event and
cover a lot of ground that i haven't
even touched before
and as a devout nerd in the space i'm
both ashamed and excited that that is
true
that's happening in the uk may 23rd to
26 and you can also
attend the live streaming
online what i should
mention tim is one thing we will be
we're talking to synergetic next week so
you'll be able to pre-order
the symposium volume for espd55
just and you can still order the old one
as well they still
they still have that so you can
pre-order that there
and
the videos from espd50
are still online and then and they're
open access and i'll send you that link
and you can post that as well so people
can go back and watch those videos
perfect
we'll include those i think we've pretty
well covered just about everything
you've been incredibly generous with
your time
life feels short sometimes but it's also
pretty long and
if i'm not going to spend time having
conversations like this what am i i
don't rush to do go fold my socks this
is much more fun
right people can find you on twitter
at dennis mckenna the number four we
will link to that in the show notes as
well
the website for
your academy is mckenna dot academy
and
the links to everything will be in the
show notes tim dot blog slash podcast if
you just search my name and dennis
mckenna no doubt you'll find both of our
episodes
and that will be very very easy to
source so team.log slash podcast
dennis it is so nice to see you again
it's always fun
always
this has been great fun we've just we
just had an amazing rant here this is
lovely
amazing rant we have a number of punk
rock band names
we have a partial book title for your
one of your next books the obscure
corners which i like a lot i took a note
on that
which was drawn from something you said
earlier
and
all in all just another extremely
thought-provoking very very enjoyable
conversation so thank you dennis thank
you and to
everybody listening as always
thank you for tuning in and until next
time be just a little kinder than is
necessary take care of yourselves be
safe and take care
you